In January 2010, inspectors with the UN’s
nuclear monitoring agency noticed something
strange at the nuclear facility in Natanz,
Iran.
Numerous centrifuges at the crown jewel of
Iran’s nuclear program were failing.
Centrifuges are devices that produce enriched
uranium which can be used to make nuclear
weapons.
The cause of their failure was a mystery.
It’s believed the U.S. and Israel ordered
a cyberattack to slow down Iran’s nuclear
program.
A computer worm called Stuxnet traveled on
USB thumb drives and spread through Microsoft
Windows computers that controlled the centrifuges,
sending instructions for them to burn out.
Stuxnet didn’t simply take over a computer
or steal information, it actually caused the
equipment to self-destruct!
It’s more dangerous than a computer virus.
While a virus is dormant until the unwitting
victim installs it, a worm can spread without
being activated.
Stuxnet is believed to have been created by
the U.S. National Security Agency and Israeli
intelligence though neither has ever admitted
responsibility.
Their collaborative effort was dubbed “Operation
Olympic Games”
It started under the Bush administration.
President Obama sped it up when he came into
office in 2009, heeding Bush’s advice to
continue the cyberattacks.
President Bush believed it was the only way
to prevent Israel from launching a conventional
strike on Iranian nuclear facilities - like
the one that targeted a Syrian nuclear reactor
in 2007.
Israel has never bought Iran’s argument
that its nuclear program is entirely peaceful,
for the purposes of generating electricity,
for example.
Iran launched its nuclear program in the 1950s
with the help of the U.S. through the Atoms
for Peace program in which America shared
resources with countries wanting to develop
atomic energy for peaceful activities.
In 1970, Iran ratified the Non-Proliferation
Treaty (NPT) to limit its program for peaceful
use.
It meant Iran would have to be subject to
inspection by the International Atomic Energy
Agency (IAEA).
Those inspectors with the IAEA noticed centrifuges
mysteriously failing at the start of 2010.
Getting the worm into the Natanz facility
was actually the final step of a carefully
planned attack.
This is what is believed to have happened.
The NSA and the Israeli military wrote a program
that digitally mapped out the workings of
Iran’s Natanz plant.
The program is introduced into a controller
computer at the plant possibly by an oblivious
plant worker.
The program collects information on how the
computers in the facility are configured
The agencies use the data to design a complex
worm - Stuxnet.
Stuxnet is introduced into the plant’s computer
controllers via a USB stick.
Stuxnet was designed to target computers with
a specific Siemens (see-mins) software program.
This program was used by industrial computers
to control and monitor the centrifuges.
The worm takes over control of the centrifuges,
causing them to spin too fast or too slow.
They become unbalanced and in some cases,
explode.
Centrifuges spin at supersonic speeds to separate
isotopes in uranium gas.
Uranium enriched to 90% or more can be used
to make nuclear weapons.
According to the New York Times, the centrifuges
first began to crash in 2008.
Initially, the attacks were small and seemed
like random accidents as variations in the
code prompted different types of breakdowns
which confused the Iranian engineers.
By the spring of 2010, the NSA and Israel’s
Secretive Intelligence Unit 8200 prepared
to ramp up their attack to target 1,000 centrifuges.
But the worm was discovered.
That summer, a programming error sent the
worm onto the laptop of an Iranian engineer.
The laptop had reportedly been hooked up to
the systems controlling the centrifuges.
The Stuxnet worm was replicated across the
internet, spreading wildly and attacking computers
in India, Indonesia, and China.
It’s eventually tracked down and disassembled
by security researchers.
President Obama decided to continue the operation
anyway, and Stuxnet took out nearly 1,000
centrifuges - or about a fifth of those operating.
There’s been debate about how the worm actually
got into the nuclear facility.
According to one theory, Israel hired an Iranian
double agent or agents to infect the facility
with a corrupt memory stick.
Another theory, according to security software
firm Symantec is that the attackers infected
computers at five outside companies connected
to the nuclear program, and somehow, managed
to find its way to Natanz.
Experts who analyzed the computer worm say
it was far more complex - and brilliant - than
anything they had ever seen.
The attackers even secretly recorded what
a normal day at the plant looked like and
then played those readings back to plant operators
so they didn’t think anything was wrong
as the centrifuges were tearing themselves
apart.
Kind of like a pre-recorded security tape
during a bank heist in movies, like Ocean’s
11.
The U.S. believes the attack set back Iran’s
nuclear program by up to 2 years.
Others believe this is an overestimation.
Iran denied that its well-known struggles
to enrich uranium were caused by Stuxnet.
The country had always insisted its nuclear
program was for peaceful purposes.
That is until a former head of Iran’s nuclear
agency let slip in 2021 that Iran’s growth
involved “satellites, missiles, and nuclear
weapons".
Fereydoun Abbas-Davani spoke to state media
on the anniversary of the assassination of
Iranian nuclear scientist Mohsen Fakhrizadeh
by the Israeli government.
Currently, the Biden administration is trying
to revive a 2015 agreement that curbs Iran’s
nuclear work in return for relief from sanctions.
It would see Iranian oil come back on the
market at a time when the U.S. has banned
Russian oil.
President Trump had exited the nuclear deal.
Critics worry that Iran could develop nukes
under the guise of working toward peaceful
ends.
The Stuxnet computer worm has vast repercussions
today.
Computer security experts have described Stuxnet
as an instruction manual of sorts.
Sean McGurk, a former cybersecurity official
at the U.S. Department of Homeland Security,
noted that the Stuxnet source code could be
downloaded, modified, and directed at new
targets.
During an interview with 60 Minutes, he said
this in reference to those who created the
sophisticated cyberweapon:
"They opened the box.
They demonstrated the capability...it's not
something that can be put back."
In 2012, Iranian hackers are believed to have
unleashed a virus against the Saudi Arabian
petroleum and natural gas company Saudi Aramco.
They stole passwords, destroyed data, and
prevented rebooting on tens of thousands of
computers.
A document leaked by Edward Snowden and provided
to The Intercept showed the NSA believed Iran
had “demonstrated a clear ability to learn
from the capabilities and actions of others.”
Strengthening the fears of the U.S. intelligence
community that Iran had learned from American
cyberattacks.
It takes a small team to make videos here
at Newsthink.
It’s really important for me to not stress
out so I can feel good and be as productive
as possible.
For the past few months, I’ve been taking
BiOptimizers’ mineral-rich supplement Magnesium
Breakthrough with my dinner every day to help
improve my sleep as I’ve been struggling
to sleep well.
And ever since, I’ve noticed that my sleep
has gotten significantly better, I hardly
wake up in the middle of the night.
Besides getting better sleep, my sponsor BiOptimizers
aims to help you beat stress and fatigue.
Most magnesium supplements fail because they’re
synthetic or use preservatives.
Whereas Magnesium Breakthrough contains all
seven critical forms of magnesium that are
truly needed to regulate the body.
To try the powerful effects of magnesium for
yourself, head to magnesiumbreakthrough.com/newsthink
to get a 10% discount.
Be sure to use the promo code: Newsthink10
at checkout.
You can click my custom link in the description
or pinned comment.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom